the war in ukraine is dominating this
year's meeting of business and political
leaders at the world economic forum in
davos switzerland earlier today
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
delivered an address
and he called for two things maximum
sanctions against russia and greater
support to help rebuild his own country
it's the first world economic forum to
be held in person since the pandemic
began
and this year's title of history at a
turning point underscores a new global
crisis
the war in ukraine is dominating
discussions at the four-day meeting of
political and business elites in davos
all russian officials have been excluded
in a special address ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky called for maximum
sanctions including cutting off all
trade with russia
he said he was grateful for
international sanctions so far but said
they should have been imposed sooner
russia started a war with ukraine back
in 2014
we are grateful for such support
but if it had happened then immediately
with this kind of unity this pressure on
governments on companies for the sake of
the fight for freedom
would russia have started this
full-scale war
it be inflicting all this damage on
ukraine and the world
i'm sure that the answer to this
question is no
several countries including germany
pledged continuing support for ukraine
as it aims to rebuild even as the
conflict rages on
germany is financially involved in
various aid programs we're as heavily
committed as possible according to our
capabilities
the fund will also be used to rebuild
infrastructure
outside of the formal meetings activists
have transformed the russian delegates
usual hq into the so-called russian war
crimes house
photos of the toll the war has taken on
ukrainian lives aim to keep the human
cost front and center for everyone at
davos this year
well for more on
this very interesting world economic
forum i'm joined by our correspondent
ben fazoulen he's in davos switzerland
for us tonight ben it's good to see you
yeah this this year's wef is unusual for
many reasons let's just start with what
we saw today
the leader of a country at war
addressing the forum talk to me about
just the significance of that
well brent as you know the world has
changed dramatically and this is the
most urgent world economic forum that
i've been to
over the past decade
in the past 50 years
it's the most significant according to
claus schwab the forum's founder
we've got these problems of global
supply chains again like we saw in the
pandemic now because of the war in
ukraine energy prices that are shooting
up inflation which has got people
worried all around the world also food
security 25 million tons of grain are
stuck in ukraine right now and can't get
out the only thing that continues to
flow is the oil and that's what zolensky
has a big problem about because it's
funding the war in ukraine for the
russians
he wants an oil embargo he wants a ban
on all banks he doesn't want the i.t
sector profiting anymore and he also
wants no trade whatsoever and he knows
he can get that from people here in
davos uh it's a tricky one though
because it's an economic balancing game
yeah and he wants things to be absolute
for example there are no russians
present at this year's world economic
forum
how significant is that
that's extremely significant every year
there'd been more and more russians
coming here um russia house
opened a few years back and that was a
great place to have a vodka shot at
night um i'd meet up with russian mates
of mine and they'd often recognize my
last name as being russian or tatar
which it actually is
and these were young budding
entrepreneurs who had fantastic ideas of
of uh not only transforming business
relations with russia and the world but
also bringing about democracy
we're not going to see that anymore
we're
seeing an isolated russia they've been
uh banned from coming to this world
economic forum
putin is also going to find himself very
isolated he's not going to be invited
along
again and
he's not going to be able to move around
the world freely anymore all of those
oligarchs are in the same position brent
yeah and it's easy to uh you know
silence out or freeze out people from a
meeting like we've got in davos but what
about the purpose of the world economic
forum you know offering solutions are we
are we hearing any solutions on how to
end this war in ukraine
well we're not expecting a peace deal to
be
made here in davos it would be something
that the organizers would would love to
see but
that's already been ruled out by the
ukrainian authorities
what
could
proceed is some sort of new deal with
ukraine which could help to slow down
this war and possibly even stop it at
some stage
i was talking about funding uh funding a
war in russia and that's exactly what
germany's doing it's totally dependent
on that russian oil so is a lot of
europe
but what some experts here are touting
is a new energy deal a new energy
partnership with ukraine ukraine has
rich wind energy which it can produce
quite cheaply it also has a lot of green
hydrogen which it can also offer europe
there's a lot of electricity uh
renewable power that can be offered to
europe
if europe is willing to shift a lot
quicker than it's saying it will and
spend a lot more money and financing in
in re-educating reschooling its workers
and moving them from things like coal
and oil to wind solar and all those
other green energies that are out there
brent
ben fazoulen at the world economic forum
ben we will be talking with you in about
15 minutes as our coverage continues
from davos switzerland thank you
i'll be here
and here are some of the other stories
now that are making headlines
regarding the war in ukraine a russian
envoy says that he has resigned because
of his opposition to his country's
invasion of ukraine boris bondarev
worked for moscow's mission to the
united nations in geneva he has written
to colleagues condemning russia's war
and he's expressed his shame
starbucks is pulling out of the russian
market the seattle coffee giant has
announced it is closing all of its 130
stores in russia the brand had initially
said that it would keep the stores open
but donate profits to humanitarian
relief efforts in ukraine
mcdonald's exited the russian markets
just last week
hungary has again refused to back an eu
ban on russian oil unless more cash is
provided for its energy infrastructure
budapest's opposition is blocking a
sixth package of european union
sanctions which must be unanimously
approved by the eu's 27 member states
you